Well,
Jamie was talking about something yesterday and I started listening to this
recent Sam Harris' podcast and it is fucking fascinating how much Russian troll
farms and all these fake accounts and what they're trying to do.
And one of the things they're trying to do is what Jamie was saying was that
that kid with the Maggot hat or the native American beat the drum in front of
them.
The image of that was posted by this website that turned out to be a Russian
troll farm,
but it was in Brazil.
Was it June as a blogger in Brazil when they'd CNN looked into it.
They just kinda asked Twitter what's going on with this account.
And by the time they'd asked them,
they just suspended the council.
It's gone.
But,
but you said they suspended account because the account was a fake account yet
they had a,
they thought it was posing as like a California teacher.
Her name is Talia,
but it was,
it was an actual blogger in Brazil.
Oh,
so it was Brazil wasn't rushing?
No,
I,
I wasn't sure.
No,
I just was,
I was saying like it was sewn into a fake account if someone's,
but yes,
they sow seeds of,
yeah,
well they're trying to get people against each other.
They're doing that in a minute.
Like people need to understand that this is actually really happening and there
we need their help.
Hurley will,
we turned against each other day.
We need the Russians help.
Well,
if you stop and think about it,
has there ever been a time with the left and the right were more,
it chose throats and right and ends enough.
You don't need to rush it was Arabic but,
but our CNN enough to really get people turned against each other like this.
No fucking way.
You need angry discourse online and the way that comes from,
there's,
there's an amazing Radiolab podcast about this where they talked to people that
actually worked in these troll farms and that these people were,
they would both be left wing and right wing and this is one of the things that
they're talking about on the Sam Harris' podcast.
It's,
I think it's called a war of information,
but they'll pose as like a pro choice people and say ridiculous shifts like over
the top.
Ridiculous.
And then they'll pose is pro life American flag.
And you know,
Magda in the,
in the,
you know,
the Hashtag man they're,
they're heading,
but they have nothing to do with that.
They're just Russians and they're just trying to get people riled up and you see
people jump on board and of course chime in.
But,
um,
I was talking to a comic that we were talking about that I won't bring his name
up,
but he referred me to this,
this Russian guy.
I can't,
I'm not going remember his name,
but this is a clip of this Russian guy who worked for the KGB defected over
here.
And he was explaining how Russia does that.
Yeah.
And this was back in the 80s.
Oh,
well we do it too.
Everybody does it.
They all do it.
They fuck with the system in any way,
shape or form in order to achieve a desired result.
I think the Russians are the best at it apparently.
Well,
I just think they're way more dedicated to it.
And then,
I mean it's a sneaky way to go about doing things too because Russia doesn't
have the,
the kind of money that the United States,
so they get nothing.
They have their economies the size of Texas.
Yeah.
All's I have is nuclear weapons there almost like a third world and a brutal
dictator,
a dictator.
That's all it takes.
But as a far as the economy and everything,
they were like a third world she had.
It's,
well they're like a small European country.
But it's really interesting when you,
you listen to these podcasts about how much effort they put into sewing
discourse or discord to getting people upset with each other,
to starting arguments and to saying things that are going to upset people in
order to get the right versus the left to like sure.
To undermine democracy from the inside.
Yeah.
It's really interesting.
I mean it's,
it's weird that it works,
but it makes sense that it works.
It's a sneaky ass strategy.
Yeah.
You think CNN does just as good a job.
They really do harm.
But you're so,
you're so right wing,
you can't,
I'm not so right when John,
how right wing far right.
Meetup.
Middle,
right.
I'd say center,
Of Center.
Right.
Of Center,
yeah.
Yeah,